the loop statement is used to process a
group of SAS statements multiple times
using loops can greatly reduce the
number of statements required for
repetitive calculations or reading huge
data sets the syntax for using do loop
is as shown here the index variable
stores the value of the current
iteration of do loop an already created
variable is eligible to become the index
for do loop the start value specifies
the initial value of the index variable
the stop value is the last index value
that executes the do loop the optional
by clause specifies an increment value
for the index variable if by Clause is
not specified the default increment
value is 1 it is important to note that
the start stop and increment values are
set upon entry into the do loop they
cannot be changed during the processing
of the do loop they can be numbers
variables or SAS expressions the end
statement terminates the loop the value
of the index variable can be changed
within the loop in the next screen we
will observe an example of do loop
the gampel will keep the amount of
interest earned each month for a
one-year investment by a person during
compilation the program data vector is
created for the finance dot earnings
data set when the data step is executed
the values of a mount and rate are
assigned the do loop is executed during
each execution of the do loop the value
of earned is calculated and is added to
its previous value then the value of
month is incremented on the 12th
execution of the do loop the program
data vector looks as shown after the
12th execution of the do loop the value
of month is incremented to 13 because 13
exceeds the stop value of the iterative
do statement the do loop stops executing
and processing continues to the next
data step statement the end of the data
step is reached the values are written
to the finance dot earnings data set and
in this example the data step ends only
one observation is written to the data
set however there might be a situation
when the user wants to store earning for
each month individually in the resulting
data set in such a case explicit output
statements are used with the do loop we
will discuss this in the next screen
fault data step contains an implicit
output statement at the end of the step
but placing an explicit output statement
overrides automatic output causing SAS
to add an observation to the data set
every time the explicit output statement
is executed for example if we use the
explicit output statement in the do loop
as shown in the program calculations for
each value of the index variable will be
stored separately in the output data set
the output will appear as shown so far
we discussed how a do loop iterates with
an increment in the index value in each
iteration however you can control the
flow of loop and some other methods too
we will discuss these methods in the
next screen